[Música]
daniela hablando conmigo otra vez en el
estudio en esta mesa de trabajo directo
américa de francés de 4 para seguir
hablando de economía daniela que pues
últimamente lamentablemente han sido
solamente malas noticias y vamos a
empezar con una no tan buenas
precisamente la comisión europea empeoró
las previsiones económicas parece años
así es raúl pues este grupo de 27 países
cree que el crecimiento será menor al
que estimaba antes y que la inflación
estará más alta por cuenta de la guerra
en ucrania y las consecuencias que ha
tenido sobre todo desde el punto de
vista de aumento de precios nuestra
corresponsal en bruselas desert herrera
nos entregó detalles más temprano
las consecuencias de la guerra en
ucrania se hacen notar en la economía
europea la comisión europea presentado
hoy sus previsiones en que prevé un
recorte del crecimiento de la unión
europea para este año pero sobre todo
para el siguiente en que prevé un
crecimiento de apenas el 1,5 por ciento
pero lo que preocupa realmente es la
inflación ahora mismo disparada la
comisión europea calcula que este 2022
la inflación supere el 8% en la unión
europea un récord absoluto en su
historia un alza de precios que se debe
sobre todo al aumento de los precios de
la energía del gas y de la electricidad
pero también al aumento de los precios
de los alimentos especialmente de los
cereales aún así la comisión europea
calcula que la inflación llega a su pico
antes de finalizar el año y pueda irse
reduciendo poco a poco muy especialmente
ya para el 2023 aún así advierte la
comisión europea y enormes
incertidumbres en la economía europea
porque la posibilidad de mayores cortes
de gas por parte de rusia hacia la unión
europea ya no es una hipótesis sino que
es un escenario cada vez más posible y
los países deben estar preparados porque
en este escenario podría aumentar aún
más la inflación y también que se
reduzca aún más la economía lo que
podría provocar enormes problemas
económicos a la unión europea muchos más
de los previstos y le decidan y en la
que iniciando esta crónica pues no
habíamos tenido tantas buenas noticias
hay una que pues sí se puede considerar
como una buena no porque en eeuu desde
eeuu y se van a reactivar unos vuelos
hacia otras ciudades de cuba que no sea
en la habana si raúl pues una buena
noticia entonces para los cubanos y pues
tantos migrantes que hay en eeuu de este
país el departamento de transporte
aprobó una solicitud que hizo american
airlines para reanudar los vuelos que se
detuvieron en 2019 en este momento la
administración del entonces presidente
de donald trump redujo drásticamente el
servicio aéreo entre los dos países
en ese momento trompo suspendió los
vuelos desde dos unidos que no fueran
directamente a la habana y hace dos
meses su sucesor joe biden revirtió esa
decisión y anunció que relajaría las
restricciones a los viajeros
estadounidenses a la isla de esta manera
entonces se van a permitir o se va a
permitir mejor que american airlines se
reanude dos vuelos diarios desde miami a
la ciudad de santa clara como lo ven en
el mapa también uno para cada aeropuerto
en baradero en holguín en camagüey y en
santiago de cuba esto a partir de
noviembre de este año como dato de
cierre le cuento que hoy solamente
viajan a la habana american airlines
jetblue y software desde eeuu y con esta
noticia también le diría que sería una
buena no pero pues hay que tocarla con
pinza y al hermetismo que hay
económicamente en venezuela no y es que
el presidente de ese país nicolás maduro
dijo que esa economía está creciendo es
raúl con decirle que para conocer el
dato de inflación hay que mirar 21 que
hace un observatorio de economistas y
otro que hace el parlamento pero nunca
está disponible el dato en el banco
central de venezuela como en el banco
central del resto de países
concretamente entonces el presidente
aseguró durante la inauguración de una
expo feria transmitida por el canal
estatal vtv que la economía va por buen
camino
y muy buenas noticias
muy buenas noticias
no me corresponde darlas a mí pero
tenemos un crecimiento de dos dígitos en
el primer semestre del año para la
economía real para la economía
productiva de venezuela venezuela va
creciendo en la economía real dos
dígitos parece una buena noticia raúl
pero no sabemos cuál es la magnitud
porque el mandatario dijo que no era
tarea suya sino del banco central
precisar la cifra exacta de crecimiento
este episodio hay que decirlo ya había
ocurrido el pasado primero de junio
cuando maduro pronunció exactamente las
mismas palabras que la economía iba
creciendo dos dígitos con la diferencia
de que en ese momento se refería al
primer trimestre lo cierto es que la
última estadística publicada
oficialmente por el banco central sobre
crecimiento económico en su página web
data de 2017 y también que el emisor
solamente ofrece datos de inflación
esporádicamente lo ha hecho dos veces
este año mientras tanto nos quedamos con
el cacao y el ron de esa feria que
estaba presidente nicolás maduro gan y
delicioso indicadores económicos no wall
street y las bolsas del mundo en general
se unen al ritmo de la inflación en eeuu
que avivó los temores de que las tasas
de interés puedan seguir eventualmente
subiendo a un ritmo más acelerado por
ejemplo en asia solamente tokio ganó en
europa las proyecciones más pesimistas
de las que estábamos hablando tiñeron de
rojo las bolsas que a media jornada
caían entre el 1 y el 2% en el caso de
españa- que nos trae como cifra el día
bueno 132 años que tomará el mundo para
alcanzar la paridad de género plena esto
según el más reciente informe del foro
económico mundial y hay
22 asuntos para destacar primero que
esto representa una leve mejora frente a
2021 cuando la estimación era de 136
años y segundo y esta es una buena
noticia para el cierre y es que aunque
ningún país ha logrado todavía la plena
igualdad de género 10 economías lo han
hecho en al menos un 80 por ciento 100
por ciento quiere decir que se reduce
toda la brecha
la cndh ya lidera el 'ranking' y
solamente hay un latinoamericana de
viene cuál es cuál es daniela nicaragua
se estrenó este año en el puesto 7 de la
lista igual 132 años es mucho esperemos
que nos alcanza la vida para ver esto
pues un poco más reducido daniela así es
como siempre muchísimas gracias por toda
la información de economía la despido
para dar la bienvenida a humanizada para
hablar de deportes